Esto que estás viendo parece una broma,
pero no lo es. Una persona con una muela
rota acercándose un cigarro encendido al
diente como si quemarlo fuese a arreglar
algo. Y aunque parezca una locura, hay
gente que hace cosas parecidas cuando
tiene un dolor dental brutal. Porque el
dolor de muelas puede llegar a ser tan
intenso que algunas personas prueban
remedios extremos, peligrosos o
directamente absurdos. Quemte un diente
con un cigarro no cura una cáis. La
caris es una infección y destrucción del
diente causado por bacterias. Si ya hay
una muela rota, un agujero o incluso
exposición del nervio, el problema está
dentro. Y aplicar calor extremo encima
puede empeorar todavía más la
inflamación, quemar tejidos, irritar la
encía e incluso aumentar el dolor
después del efecto momentáneo. Porque
sí, a veces el calor o el daño nervioso
puede generar una sensación temporal
rara como de alivio, pero es una falsa
sensación. Es como apagar la alarma
mientras la casa sigue ardiendo. Porque
cuando una muela está destruida, que se
rompe y se ve oscura u agujereada,
muchas veces ya hablamos de una cares
profunda, una infección del nervio, una
necrosis de la pulpa o incluso un
abceso. Y esto puede acabar con dolor
insoportable, inflamación de la cara,
pus, fiebre o necesitar una endodoncia o
extracción si se deja avanzar. Así que
si alguna vez tienes un dolor tan fuerte
que te hace pensar en cosas
desesperadas, ni ajo, ni alcohol, ni
aspirinas quemando laancía y desde luego
ni cigarrillo sobre el diente, porque
internet está lleno de remedios caseros,
pero algunos parecen sacados de un
experimento medieval. Tu dentista te
juzgará menos de lo que crees, pero la
infección esa sí que no perdona. Yeah.